[Music]
welcome to our session covering the
professional google workspace
administrator training and certification
we have some great opportunities to
share with you and your teams
i'm mara sauce the google cloud
credentials engagement lead
with the demand for google workspace
skills increasing our partners and
customers are looking to grow their team
of professionals with the validated
google workspace skills to help them
achieve their digital transformation and
productivity goals
getting your team certified can be the
first step in not only improving client
satisfaction it are also a great way to
invest in skills development for your
teams
recently collected data states that
nearly 70 percent of organizations
recognize that certifications speed up
technology implementation leading to
greater staff productivity
the same report also found that 85
percent of it consultants agree
that certification represents validation
of extensive product and process
knowledge
finally foley certified teams are 35
more likely than partially certified
teams to finish projects ahead of
schedule
typically reaching their targets more
than two weeks early
to talk more about the job role of a
google workspace administrator and the
impact that the professional google
workspace administrator certification
can have on your business and career i
welcome kimberly google workspace
customer engineer
certified workspace administrators have
an important role at any organization
they enable people to work together
communicate and access data in a secure
and efficient manner
operating with an engineering and
solutions mindset they use tools
programming languages and apis to
automate workflows
the google workspace training and
certification offers to grow and
showcase your team's skills help them
gain confidence in their abilities and
stay current to give their company a
competitive edge
i've worked with businesses evaluating
and deploying google workspace for seven
years at google and as a customer
engineer i've seen firsthand how the
certification helps my customers achieve
business goals faster and solve their
organization's toughest business
challenges quicker with a team that has
the right cloud skills
with my customers who have gone through
the training and achieved the
certification they have seen accelerated
deployment timelines hardened security
and quicker resolution to it issues on
an ongoing basis
i worked with one customer with several
thousand users facing a re-up on their
on-prem exchange server their extremely
lean it team didn't have the bandwidth
to manage everything and leadership
preferred not to expand hiring but
they've been using their current
solution for decades to make matters
even more difficult their industry was
facing new compliance requirements for
handling sensitive data so they really
needed to reduce time spent
administering while avoiding any gaps in
security
the workspace training and certification
helped their existing it team translate
their experience administering their
current systems and learn google best
practices not just solving the same
problems with replacement features but
finding actual new approaches to solve
those business challenges in a more
secure and automated way they were even
able to solve a new few new business
challenges along the way with their
newfound skills in deploying zero trust
you're the expert on how your
organization operates today but the
google professional workspace
administrator certification can build
your team of experts and unlock google
technology to propel your business
forward
validate your team's google workspace
expertise with the professional google
workspace administrator certification
get your team started today with 30 days
of free hands-on training through our
on-demand platform google cloud skills
boost
best of luck in your training and
certification journey